et bien bonjour je suis avec mon accent
sofiane et sa bienvenue les amis nous
allons jouer un jeu aujourd'hui harry
très peu d'ambiance dans ce 2
le silence était là on va jouer un jeu
où on va tester votre improvisation tu
fait du doublage du noble âge tu as fait
du doublage
vous avez dû improviser devant une
séquence ok là vous allez faire la même
chose mais à l'écrit ça est souvent en
dessous titre on a joué à dubaï faille
qu'à victoria legrand j'y adhère fois
c'était très amusant l'ess a énormément
plu aux gens dont je décide de vous
inviter des gens qui vont accepter plaît
c'est la première game dont l'un d'eux
jean sera présente vous en faites pas ok
écoutez chevallier non là il parle pas
les mecs qui veulent être au fond c'est
génial on est prêt ouais ok c'est parti
[Musique]
jamais ça c'est moche y aller ça fait
plaisir
ok maintenant ça fait un journal d gaza
est une photo ok ok députation découvert
de la photo
[Musique]
chatr [ __ ] merde à irriguer pas le de
ce qu'est la vie à aumetz gm est un truc
une bulle si je cliquer sur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme ce fut nul je me faisais arrête
tout genre sont nuls
écoutons phrase tu veux en faire un tipi
pour toi fais ça allait acheter 2 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
évidente
oui mais la star
hu la cotation non vous pouvez faire du
monde noir doit aller là bas j'avais
fait dans la vidéo d'abord j'ai même
fait dans la vie de cette retenue d'eau
fantastique ces tests est digne des plus
grands quand les mecs attention non non
l'humour noir ou pas mais qu'est ce que
t'es pas obligé l affaire du lac
l'armement
jésus a ouvert une caméra cachée depuis
le départ
[Rires]
elle
[Musique]
très bon football
des amis je propose la belle là les
vestes c'est bon la dernière la
meilleure celui qui gagne celle ci va
tout mettre en jeu on la met sur le
micro pareil je suis partagé [ __ ] j'ai
envie d'en refaire je suis déçu
[Musique]
il est bien libye a libéré
le mien c'est le pire de ce que j'ai mis
en liberté l'islamiste une claque
l'argentin joue pas drôle mais propre
[Musique]
walk in et les amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo
gmac a vous a plu ces gars n'était pas
lui mais que tu n'hésitais pas et
surtout ça fait plus à aller voir la
chaîne de maxence aller vers la chaîne
de surfer en arrivant la chaîne sème la
frite tous les nerfs sont la description
et s'affichera aussi dans l'outro qui
font des très bonne vidéo
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est pas non pas
maintenant pas au foot mais lors du
clasico la whey aux jeunes bien ouais
ouais ouais
les amis en exclusivité vous pouvez
faire une dédicace à votre collection
alors que les jeux voilà c'est fini
cette année était bien la vidéo ou pas
on finit sur le nouveau mode fin de
toutes mes vidéos
4 ayew
[Musique]